breaking news stunning 30 40 50 the
ruble 260 and ever weaker Russian rubles
a signal of this to domestic Russia and
of course to their international
relations profound let me start Brendan
Greeley with what a 60 ruble means for
Germany i mean this does destabilize it
relationship does well this is a problem
at germany as hot as the germany needs
to learn how to lead and with every drop
in the ruble it becomes a little more
urgent for angela miracle to do
something she's been doing things bits
and pieces of things she is our lifeline
to Vladimir Putin but there at some
point Germany is going to have to
recognize that diplomatically it has to
lead I'm gonna get this chart out on
Bloomberg radio plus but let me make it
real clear warable weakens beyond 75 vs
euro Olivia it's not just about dollar
ruble oh it's about their entire line
remember joke in Russia these days
everything's heading towards 63 Vladimir
Putin's age the ruble and also the price
of oil really all the brent is now below
60 a we dodged a rushing joke Greta but
we passed the Russian joke you know
Congress agreed this weekend to pass
those sanctions against Russia to give
Obama though right run waited to get
Brenda Greeley within your reading on
this is is Russia Zimbabwe is Russia
name another country Olivia venezuela
venezuelan know they've got I mean
they've got resources I mean even if oil
is selling low they've got oil to sell
but I mean the question that nobody can
answer olivia is that you know at what
point in the drop in the ruble or the
drop in the price of oil does Vladimir
Putin freaked out seems to be never
never he has what a 250 million dollar
worchester spinners he's spending it
slowly they ask he's helping the likes
of rosneft refinance yeah but that is a
drop in a bucket to 250 million dollars
and I think the one of the things that
we're seeing with this war chest they've
made a conscious decision they cannot
protect the price of the room whether
they're willing to admit it publicly
they know that they can